the form you want to know when you're
compounding continuously is the perk
formula and it's oftentimes written as a
equals P e raised to the RT power and
the P just represents the principle
that's what you're starting with E is
the natural base e 2.71 and then R is
the interest rate you want to convert
that into a decimal by moving the
decimal point two places to the left and
then T is the time generally in years so
let's get into an example and just talk
about how to work with this so say you
start with a thousand dollars and the
interest rate is five percent and you're
just trying to figure out well how long
is going to take to double your money
right so let's go ahead and use our
formula so we've got a equals PE to the
RT power and we're trying to find out
let's see the principal is a thousand
right we want to end up with two
thousand e to the interest rate point O
five I'm just moving that decimal point
two places to the left to convert it to
a decimal and then we're trying to solve
for T time right okay so what you can
think about doing is you can think about
working from the outside in towards the
variable right so what we're going to do
is we're going to divide both sides by a
thousand okay so you can see those are
cancelling this is reducing to two so
now we have two equals e to the point
zero five T we want to get that T by
itself but we can see that it's in the
exponent position okay it's up here as a
power so what we're gonna do is we're
going to take the natural log of both
sides logs and exponential functions
they're inverses of one another they
undo or cancel one another out now a
natural log the Ln here you don't see it
but it's understood to be base E so the
natural log base E and this exponential
function base either undoing one another
you get point zero five T equals natural
log of two and we're going to divide
both sides by 0.05 now to get the time
by itself let's go to the calculator
let's see what that comes out to we have
let's see natural log of 2 divided by
0.05 and we're getting about thirteen
point nine years so I'm just going to
approximate it as fourteen years so that
would be your time to double if it's
compounded continuously at 5% so I hope
this video helped you to understand how
work with a perk for me a little bit
better and figuring out time to double
go ahead and subscribe to the channel
check out more math videos on my youtube
channel Mario's math tutoring and I look
forward to seeing in the future videos
I'll talk to you soon